felicidades ahora entiende el lenguaje
javascript variable saltos cadenas
funciones objetos arreglos e incluso
diseño orientado a objetos pero qué tan
bueno es un lenguaje si no puedes hacer
cosas interesantes con él hay muchas
maneras en las que puedes usar tus
conocimientos nuevos pero una de las
maneras más populares de usar javascript
con procesamiento de datos es haciendo
juegos y visualizaciones lo cual tal vez
ya sabes si es que has visto nuestra
lista de los mejores programas un juego
es algo interactivo en el que obtienes
alguna recompensa generalmente hay un
estado de ganador de perdedor una
puntuación una visualización es algo más
interactivo pero sin la mecánica del
juego vamos a echar un vistazo a los
componentes comunes que necesitaremos
vamos a necesitar controles we para
cualquier cosa que estemos haciendo como
botones y deslizadores y menús algunos
serán botones sencillos otras veces
necesitaremos múltiples botones otras
veces deslizadores y desplegables y todo
se construye con los mismos principios
básicos además de interactuar con el
ratón también queremos controles de
teclado para usar flechas y mover a
nuestros personajes hacia arriba y hacia
abajo o cambiar el ángulo de la
visualización
también queremos tener la noción de
escenas una escena es como tu pantalla
de inicio una pantalla opcional y tu
pantalla principal y tu pantalla final y
generalmente son muy diferentes y en
cualquier punto dado queremos mostrar
una u otra así que realmente tienes que
organizar tu código con el propósito de
saber las diferencias entre las escenas
y tener una forma correcta de cambiar
entre ellas y ahora vamos a hablar de
algunas cosas específicas de los juegos
el ambiente del juego es un deslizador
lateral lo que significa que hay un
personaje que avanza a través de un
espacio
es una vista de pájaro que va a través
de un laberinto
es un ambiente en tercera dimensión es
una locura pero puedes hacerlo hay
muchos niveles y cada nivel tiene un
entorno diferente
cuáles son los personajes del juego los
personajes probablemente tienen
diferentes comportamientos y emociones y
estados como estar feliz o estar muerto
y eso podría ser controlado por el
usuario o algunas veces eso podría ser
controlado mediante programación y tu
programa tiene una cierta lógica que
debe seguir podría haber un personaje o
podrían ser muchos o podrían ser creados
mientras juegas ahora una vez que
tenemos personajes en un ambiente
generalmente añadimos más elementos y
luego tenemos un montón de cosas que
chocan entre sí y queremos saber cuándo
las cosas chocan porque las cosas
normalmente se tratan de atraer o se
tratan de evitar como cuando estás
recogiendo gemas o tratando de evitar
las desagradables tortugas así que debes
ser capaz de detectar las colisiones
entre los objetos y algunas veces son
colisiones simples otras veces son más
complejas y los objetos tienen
diferentes tamaños y formas finalmente
si es un juego podría tener un marcador
como mides que tan buen desempeño tiene
el usuario cuando le dice si ganó o
perdió qué tan espectacular puedes hacer
tu escena
triunfo de derrota así que como puedes
ver hay muchos aspectos que considerar
cuando haces juegos o visualizaciones
vamos a revisar algunos aquí pero no
sabemos que hay en tu cabeza y lo más
probable es que tengas que combinar el
conocimiento que has aprendido aquí para
crear las cosas maravillosas que están
en tu cabeza en este momento